we're all more powerful than we think we
are especially in this internet era
where anybody can you know go online
with a camera or a microphone and you
know share themselves and and I can tell
you that being engaged in the process of
like trying to offer something positive
to the world and and and not get caught
up in metrics and well that guy's doing
this and he's bigger than me and like
why is that guest doing the you know
like when I get for when I free myself
of all of that noise and just remember
like why it is that we're doing this
it's just like an overwhelming sense of
like gratitude I want everyone to feel
their version of of that and I think
it's we're in a time in a in a place
where that's more possible than it ever
has been in history I just think
everybody has something inside of them
that they could express to make the
world a little bit of a better place I
think everybody you know can make a
difference in the world